[Musique]
e
frédérick gersal j'ai le grand honneur
d'être le parrain de l'historial du
poitou qui ouvrira ses portes pour en
2022 j'ai eu la chance aujourd'hui de
visites et de faire une visite de
chantier à l'invitation du sénateur
bruno belin une visite de ce chantier de
ce que va devenir justement de ce que
sera cette historial que je parraine et
ça va être quelque chose de mirifiques
on le voit d'ailleurs derrière moi deux
châteaux de long sur gan sera le lieu
d'habitation de cette historial là où
seront tous les trésors qui vont nous
raconter notre histoire avec autour
d'aliénor d'aquitaine de son fils
richard coeur de lion et puis de la
guerre de cent ans et puis de tout ce
qui devait être le mode de vie aussi du
quotidien pour nos ancêtres on va
replonger dans l'histoire et cette
visite m'a fait chaud au coeur et on se
dit que on attend avec impatience
l'année 2022 qui sera
[Musique]
on a besoin de savoir si ce qu'on fait
ce soir on a besoin de partager des
moments de culture c'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire on a besoin d'avoir un peu
d'espoir et d'enthousiasmé
heureux partager ce moment là parce que
finalement le meilleur mot qui va être
la culture ces partages il n'y a pas de
culture sans partage y'a pas d'ennuis
sans partage gap a deux passions son
partage
des moments de rencontre plutôt et le
conseil départemental en propose tout
l'été le biais d'ag abondent les gens
regardent donc voilà ça pour détendre
les landes retrouvailles on en a besoin
donc je vous évite ce soir pour l'avant
dernier concert de nouvel an à civaux et
de la soie pour le concert
[Musique]